hello
everybody it's your favorite married
couple
ethan and neil klein
we're basically the perfect relationship
if you didn't already know
i had to just come out and tell you i'm
just kidding guys i'm just kidding
because that's what everyone
says and i'm just trying to play it up
like hey it's ethan and healer the
perfect relationship we just love each
other
it's like the youtube thing you know all
right then
our happy beautiful son the next
video is like so we broke up
yeah exactly that means the divorce is
coming
soon ethan is going to take over the
channel and
did you think we would take over the
second channel who do you think went out
for pizza without me
yeah i know it's who do you think would
handle a divorce better
if we got
it's just fun not good question
just thought it'd be a fun debate okay
now we're really getting divorced
that will never happen okay whatever but
we're here to have fun but
what kind of intros is ethan exactly
okay start no we can't we're live
there's no retakes here welcome
everybody
first of all thank you to all of our
members who make this possible you know
we love
our members we love you we love you they
love you
you subscribe you get early episodes you
hit that uh joy button we love the
members
yes
um do we have ads today dan oh we sure
do
it's not my doc what do we got you tell
you thank him for me today's episode
is brought to you by roman and
me undies oh we love
them we love it okay today we've got all
kinds of
adventures and stories and fun you know
i've been trying to think because we
brought back the
normal h3 podcast uh
format this week how do we differentiate
after dark live in the normal episode
here's the difference after dark
no covet talk no politics
nothing serious only fun and raunchy
madness right h3 podcast
that's where my controversial hot takes
will come that many of you will watch
and be like
you you'll see either ethan is out of
touch ethan is wrong about this topic
ethan ethan
uh has fallen from grace stick to comedy
et cetera so if you go like all that
that's where you'll find it
[Laughter]
but yeah i forgot the you know the
origins of after dark was to be the
escape right so
we got to stay true so here you go first
of all we have some really important
denounce
speaking of not talking about covid ian
has coveted
i'm going to have to acknowledge it it's
actually not funny at all but that was
funny so
sorry ian ian how the frick first of all
i'm so sorry you got you sent us to the
news this morning that you have coveted
and i don't understand because you don't
you haven't
left your house i mean you've been so
safe
yeah dude it's like
oh you got the positive up behind you oh
no
it's a it's a certain certified bra
moment for sure
bro what is so okay so
you did was this from a driving clinic
or how did you get the test
was it i got the little swabby
and then how many days afterwards did
you get the news
i freaking deep throated that swab so
good
they have to find the virus yeah
to get the virus of course and dig it
out you know
you got to get it real deep in your
throat and um
i got the results about a day and a half
later nice
what's that you can't sit down by
yourself it's still weird
so ian what did they say did they call
you
do you get the results like normal
people like i'm curious did contact
tracers contact you like
what what happened i uh just got an
email
around uh probably 2 a.m 2 or 3 a.m
and then you get a text too so i woke up
i was having trouble sleeping i woke up
around like
like 4 30 and then i saw the text
and and checked it and i figured oh if i
had covered they would have called me
right right i was like oh i'm safe but i
logged in anyway and uh
yeah immediately
left the room didn't want to infect sam
if she doesn't have it already but i
don't know
she has it she yeah she's just just by a
matter of
yeah she's she is it's gigi gigi
yeah it's definitely gg for anyone in
that house
so wait oh no the slide was slowed down
come on
yeah so we're gonna i mean we're both
gonna go get tested again tomorrow
just to make sure but i i feel like i
have it
having a little trouble breathing oh god
i mean not heavy
but like i like i threw a cat toy to
reuben last night and then i went and
picked it up and i was kind of like
oh [ __ ] like i was feeling it so yeah
did you get the test just as a matter of
routine or because you were feeling sick
i was feeling a little off i was i've
been fatigued
a lot and i've been getting headaches
and i've been coughing a lot i'm
surprisingly not coughing right now but
the last few days i've been coughing a
lot so god so sorry dude
yeah i mean it just goes to show you you
know you
i i take hand sanitizer everywhere i
never take my mask off like
i know you're so careful and it's it's
still got me
so that's just kind of so [ __ ] great
that's what of all the people of all of
us to get it i would
i would suspect you least of all to get
it
yeah i mean that's that's just the thing
it's so quick it just happens
you know damn so are you are you
experiencing
one of the more unusual symptoms that
i've seen a lot of people say is that
they lose
smell and taste does that happen to you
yeah i didn't think it was happening to
me but then sam
gave me a bunch of candles to smell last
night
she was like some seems off smell this
and i was like
i'm not i'm not getting not really
getting much out of here
and that was kind of like a bit of a
brittle you know wrestling she tried the
butt candle oh yeah that'd be the
ultimate that would overpower anything
have you seen these tick tocks where
people are like chugging like lime juice
and all this
insane [ __ ] they're like nope can't
taste anything i always wondered if
they're playing it up
so would you be willing to guinea pig
yourself for us like something like that
wait to do what so on tick tock there's
this trend of people who get covered
they go just to prove to you that i
can't taste anything they'll take like a
shot of lime juice
or what's other [ __ ] you've seen at ab
what else do they do all kinds of
ridiculous they'll eat like garlic or
take a bite or an onion
yeah garlic and onions are the two most
common ones i've seen wasabi
would you shop yeah do you have an onion
in your house
or garlic uh i'll check
we might as well make the best of the
situation would i take a big old bite of
an onion
yeah apparently they say they say it
doesn't taste like anything
i go full shrek on them yeah
oh look i'll take a look i don't know
what kobe did to you but you're really
funny
yeah what do you want what do you think
it's the covet i think it's the dayquil
does that to a person what do you what
sign me up dude i was telling zach i
feel like i've been
you know freaking i've been blasting off
he
[Music]
your show now
oh what's up the angels put on a space
helmet
fast enough baby yeah sometimes you just
got a glass what is going on
dude ian's gotta i think you need covet
forever
bit weird yeah i don't know
i don't actually know what's happening
all right dude ian was cracking me up
before the show he was for a good half
hours making me laugh
but are you on are you on any medicine
or is this just straight covered
i'm really i'm really not on anything
so why do you think you've become so
entertaining
well i've been getting all these
messages like oh i'm keeping you in my
prayers dude
and i think it's over for me you have
prayer power are you people are treating
me like i'm about to like
it's over i should start digging up back
yeah so maybe you've just
you have nothing to lose so you're
bearing it all for us
yeah it's you know
like i said i blasted off i have you in
my non-existent prayers
i pray for you doug i did pray if i did
pray you'd be there
bro i'm praying for you i'm praying for
you everybody in the chat
push p let's get some p's and then get
some peas
everybody playing some f's no no no no
no you're you're the
god you're the p god well you know p is
pretty much an f if you just erase a
tiny little bit of it so
p for the prayer f for the funeral vp
for peace like peeing
poor eating that's covered man we're
making the best of it out here though so
your top artist was zach lewis
my name is
your top artist on spotify with zach
lewis ian he's so
bad yeah i mean you got to support the
the legend yeah that's very sweet yeah
zach you're a big kanye god of music so
zach why are you in a suit what is this
about why are you like all like real
estate agent out
well i'm trying to be my father no
kidding um
um well they uh
they wanted me you're scaring me what's
going on here
to dress up as the joker
for like a surprise today for whatever
[ __ ] reason
and i didn't have any makeup so i'm like
oh like i'll just wear like was that
ian's idea
it was ian and dan we just off-handedly
mention it'd be funny if you just
because he loves dressing up like the
joker he's like the joker guy
he was like you should and i just
off-handedly was like you should just
come to the show
as the joker one day and somehow that
resulted in him when he was wearing his
suit
i look fly as [ __ ] boy i mean i like it
it's not the joker though and yeah it's
definitely not the joker
you know what's great about ian having
cove is if he does die we have the robot
and people won't even notice
stop it that's not great that's not not
a good joke what i'm kidding we're
joking about going you guys can i can't
make jokes about either you can't say
the d word yeah oh yeah and he said
i thought we were all joking about him
dying everyone was just typing p's in
the chat
i know i thought we were friends that's
disgusting
i don't want ian to die i'm just saying
if he does just not
even say the d word if has anyone
actually died from corona
right right if he does we have the robot
i'm just saying
zach you look like you're gonna propose
or something look i'm praying for him
what more can i do
he did drop a lot of p's in the chat um
yeah i did i called you massive prayer
i i uploaded this earlier can we please
get zach to dress up like the joker but
he
instead of face white face paint he uses
mayonnaise
that's a [ __ ] great idea zack
you know that's a good idea i've seen
your ass on tick tock just downing
mayonnaise like a psycho
yeah what yeah man did anyone do it at
you
there were a few people that do edit me
yeah i want to see that
i got to pull that up somebody sent me
that on discord
i want to see this [ __ ] i have a joker
brain
i've come to the conclusion that sounds
kind of scary you're fully jokerfied
i'm like scared of my brain to come to
that point
wow are you damaged dude
deeply how's the relationship going with
the uh
what the lovely uh what's her name again
uh jane
jane yeah uh it's going great
that's awesome i'm i'm very happy for
you dude
that and the parents are still okay
thank you yeah
nice yeah everything's everything's good
everything's kosher
no drama it's all good okay drama
you know i mean that my parents wanted
me to bring home a nice jewish girl and
i did
so oh is she jewish yeah what the hell
they have to complain about
i feel like that trump you're not you
want to jewish anything else
exactly you only get one wish
i feel like a jewish a real jewish mom
would be like you know what
i'm i'm willing to look overlook
literally anything if she's jewish
yeah and that that was like one of the
first things we bonded over
like talking about our bar and bot
all right guys you want to see what the
[ __ ] going on on tick tock and zach's
world it's getting
crazy out there shirtless oh i can't
listen to the [ __ ] i'm a ghost yeah
zach is shirtless eating mayonnaise he's
got it on his nose he's munching on it
he swallowed it and then he said
shirtless but he's got a cleavage
well he's just wearing a jacket open a
denim jacket open but no
undershirt why did you feel compelled to
do this why are you not wearing a shirt
oh okay wait what was that he said
because he looks good
really he said and then the caption is
do you think this is a sex icon thing no
i'm just trying to
i do i actually did two more i down
ranch and then i did mayonnaise too
and you're doing this just for the fun
wait mayonnaise well he says
in the caption do it me i dare you so i
was curious how do i see people who do
edit you how do i do that
um just to be logged in you might have
to be on the app i don't know
yeah that works i think you have to be
on it i think it'd be in the app so here
so
this is the one i just watched you did
it with this mayonnaise you did it with
this mayonnaise yeah oh one's miracles
some faces
are asking why are you red and sweaty
red and sweaty is that on camera right
now he doesn't look sweaty yeah we're in
the tick tock
oh and this one why are you ready to
sweaty in the ticker honestly i feel
like it sometimes the lighting just does
that
well i also have something called
rosacea where i have like a chronic red
face
rosacea oh [ __ ] yes people on the track
just did an ableism big time
that sounds like here he is
making fun of me so let me ask you guys
making fun of
a clinical that's right it's rosacea
relationship chat is cancelled okay zach
tell me you have you did one with best
what is it called best uh hellman's best
food
that's that one's mayo the other one we
watched was miracle whip it's a little
different
so why did you did you go to the grocery
store and explicitly buy these for this
video
no i'm like because i you know i got
like a joker brain and like you know
you're kind of [ __ ] up you don't have
a joke
that means you want to kill someone kind
of hold on hold on
i mean it does you shouldn't say that
but you had these on stock
these i'm like i was like at post dinner
like putting you know help put [ __ ] away
and i'm like oh there's some mayo i'm
like oh [ __ ] it
just [ __ ] it so do your parent oh so
these were already open
uh correct yeah the mirror the miracle
whip was wait where ends like
oh look at that ian's what got zach as
the
joker ian are you worried though like
for real about the covet thing like how
are you feeling about it
sam brought me the full spread i've got
here let me turn my thing it sounds like
you're kind of having a good time i'm
not even gonna hate because you last
night you're like
i have coved boys and i'm already in bed
playing video games and making the best
of it
i've seen queens gambit yep
the whole show that's what's up right
um you know what i want to freaking deez
nuts baby
i've got a lemon an onion and garlic
yes i'm so excited okay
we are doing the covet taste test this
this is here
i've seen all these people on tik tok
playing it up like you can't taste
anything and i'm wondering how true is
it so we have our own
beautiful salaried employee here ian who
has been
cursed with coveted but we're making the
best of it and which are we going to
start with here today
first i got to just note sam ran to get
me an onion
she was so excited she bought it so no
like she made a whole little spread can
you ask sam
wow if you guys have like soy sauce or
something that you can drink as well
oh my god i'm sure she's listening so
we'll see okay
because oh does she listen to the show
while we're doing it live that's so cool
yeah yeah she's off in the other room
all right i'll start with this onion
okay let's see it go ahead get a gold so
i just give it a whole bite
go for it just munch into it and chew it
and let's see like an apple like you
were eating an apple
all right it was a shrek bite i know i
need a shrek
a swamp bite i wish we could play some
shrek music
somebody
[Music]
bro i don't really taste anything are
you
[Applause]
yeah such a subtle very subtle kick
though not too much
because usually biting into an onion is
that something that you would recoil at
i think i would yes that sounds that
sounds about right
wow we've got the shrek background up
and everything
wow okay yeah he's so quick with those
backgrounds yeah i know ian is a
background master he's like a background
ninja
coming up next what do we have this is
garlic piece of garlic
a straight up clove of garlic now is
this something you would usually
eat without covering my eyes are
watering a little but i don't taste
anything
that's funny would you usually eat a
straight clove of garlic uh
i don't think i probably would make that
call okay
let's see it here we go whole clove in
the mouth raw
you know what's the real test to know if
sam's got it is if she's willing to sit
next to you after this
yeah right because the smell yeah you
know it tastes like
[Music]
my tongue is kind of like i just drank
like
you know battery acid yeah it's spicy
but i'm not like being really
like overwhelmed by it
well it's just like burning my tongue a
little bit it's very spicy i ate a raw
club
uh recently just i don't know why and i
was for the show
was it for the show with the cheese
monsters for the show and it was very
spicy
yeah it's got a little you know i'm
still i'm still feeling it way more than
the onion way
so i think the rice has just the lemon
as if sam if you're
if you're um with us something like
lemon or lime juice and soy sauce i'd
like to see
he could pump you full of all these
weird uh sam if you're watching can you
turn the stream off come on
come on oh thank you ian quick oh
oh okay sit down
okay he's sucking on a lemon just
straight up
eating a lemon well the plus side is so
that maybe all of this is really healthy
for you
he ate the entire lemon nothing whoa
oh my god that's pretty easy he's even
standing up i mean
he didn't even i would like to note that
he didn't grimace or
squint or exhibit any signs of sour
flavor
i'd like to say even though this looks
like it's fun it's a good time don't
don't get covered everyone stay safe
yeah
we're just trying not to be depressed
about it
yes how does that feel biting into a
lemon and not tasting anything how odd
yeah i don't know it's just kind of um
it's just um now i can
freaking eat my own cooking am i right
i would just munch on some broccoli just
stay healthy
you know if you can't taste anything why
not i mean some people reported that
they would lose it for like a month or
two yeah that's scary
well we're gonna have our own little
guinea pig here with us
ian please stand up please stand
up so you have no idea how you caught it
huh
no i do not why was trump in the chat
trump's a fan big time all right well i
guess it's time to move on oh ian while
i have you here i wanted to
ask you about this sorry i'm having a
gerd moment guard mama
man so this is realty free right here
this post with
on from ian's instagram the music is
yeah okay great yes it is
let me guys well i have ian here let me
show you this video this is from
middle school talent show ian with the
napoleon dynamite
yeah dude those are sick
[Music]
that's hot
[Music]
yeah it's uh i
studied i burned that napoleon dynamite
vhs tape
yeah i was wondering how much rehearsing
this this took
so it took me weeks i would get home
from school and then i'd go
into the back room with some powerade
say some mountain dew potatoes literally
what he does in the movie you were just
reenacting the movie
yeah everybody was like a school show
talent talent show you were sexy
you know i was in seventh grade zach so
that's a little sketchy if you
say yeah that's pretty gross dude i
gotta say
you've always been a little bit of a
character eh but so wait
you weren't that um like you
that's a lot of courage to do that okay
shot there bro
people are saying nicole ian dynamite
do you remember any of those moves no
it's been so long
maybe i was sick then too and it gave me
the confidence well hold on
what can we do to maybe make you relearn
all those because i bet you could
relearn it fast because you've already
done it once it's somewhere in your
brain
i'd love to see that break out again
sometime
maybe he's got the moves he could teach
me does he
yeah he does all these michael jackson
moves makes me really uncomfortable
yeah he's like all michael jackson
obsessed he calls it i never labeled him
michael jackson wait wait wait wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait wait bro you're doing you're
doing michael jackson moves how are you
going to deny it
every every dancer does those moves like
just as easily the extra moves
why are you trying to pretend like
you're not a michael jackson sim i think
went into
eight straight podcast talent show oh
that's a good idea
and i don't even know why i'm proposing
it because i will not have the courage
to do anything
we'll figure something out all right
let's move on bad idea
let's move it on
too mad we stand too mad i just bought i
bought it from his store because i
thought it was great
and then i got to support the real ones
out there
um all right we gotta get to some
serious stuff here ela
okay well i just want to say ian i just
couldn't believe that video and i still
can't believe it and uh
congratulations ian is full of surprises
today from because
yeah that's the biggest one yeah just
covered really
that was a big surprise all right what
we got on the docket
i believe it got you bro all right thank
you thank you thank you
i'll take it from here so you guys all
know
uh critical on youtube okay you guys
probably
many of you know who he is okay okay
you guys gave me a a re-upload this is
that's pretty cold-blooded
you guys put a really uploaded video on
the dock like what don't give him the
views
no let's pull it up okay it's right here
it's next to it original video
maybe for backup well isn't this this is
just a short segment of it but yeah i
guess
oh it was yeah i was an extra in the
hunger games
let me see dude this guy uploads a lot
of videos lately [ __ ] me
this was like what the [ __ ] you uploaded
like a billion videos since this [ __ ]
went up
uh oh i saw you in coughing oh [ __ ]
no you can't get it through zoom can you
you got to get me off the screen that's
gonna keep happening
this morning i learned that i am a foot
fetish icon
voted the best feat on youtube kind of
like how pollen of troy had an entire
war fought over her beauty
the foot fetishists are fighting a war
over my feet
that's how beautiful they are sorry and
i can't say i'm really surprised
i want to smell feces making sure
they're well
hydrated off any excess crust and skin
flakes
keeping them in tip top near mint
condition shape
psa 10 feet
here's the part i guess that that ian
pulled where he says
he says well let's let you this morning
i learned that i am a foot female this
is literally the beginning of the video
that i was watching
all right well there you go i don't know
i don't know why
base and i found jackson this is super
cute okay here is
my feet have actually broken their
metric here i've gone above and beyond
what science does are you kidding me
how incredible my feet are but i wanted
to see how my
feet ranked against other popular
youtubers feet so i did a little
research of my own to see who else is
entered into this database
and i found jacksepticeye has a page so
i wanted to see how sean talks about
jacksepticeye
he's it's almost like he's coming out
here trying to appeal to wikifeet
and it still wasn't good enough only a
pathetic 5.44 out of five dawn was no
contest who else could challenge my
reign as the best feat on youtube and i
thought well naturally the next match
will probably be markiplier right but
then as it turns out
markiplier with a measly five
charles white's wikifeed here so
markiplier was no
threat here and i thought
how embarrassing didn't even stand a
chance against me
so now all of you know that i have the
best feet out of any youtuber or
perhaps any person on the planet well
you're first of all charlie that's
incorrect sorry
i got it i have i gotta call you out
dude stop first of all how embarrassing
that you're gonna come out here and
throw the gauntlet down
that's it oh yeah bring out the wiki
feet hats bro do you even own a wiki
feed hat you [ __ ] hack
to say i have to say i not only have the
best feed on youtube
now but i have the best feet on wiki
feet bro do you
even do your research like i mean this
is just embarrassing for you sorry bro
look look at this wikifeet ethan
wikifeet ethan that's one of the top
suggested search results you can dan's
not being able to show it
he's getting published
look at this dan hurry wikifeet ethan
that's one of the top suggested well
that's just for you
no it's not i've never trust me dude we
cleared the cash on that browser
just the other day so that is that is
6.4
dude you are out of your element bro how
dare you come and make that
i think i need to return to my youtube
channel just to make a
that'd be kind of funny actually yeah
yeah
like a drama video come back for the
feet drama
do you zoom in on it i really want to
make sure yeah hey charlie
next time you want to come out and talk
[ __ ] and [ __ ]
take awards and all this [ __ ] read
the [ __ ]
read the room i mean this it's just
humiliating everyone in the chat is
saying he's trolling what the [ __ ] are
you talking about
you read the chat from there that's what
somebody's that's what av said
yeah everyone's yeah i mean
what do you mean he's trolling he made a
video proclaiming that his feet are the
best is he trying
like is he trying to bait you trolling
what kind of it's insane is he baiting
this conversation right now for for some
40 chess move that he's planning out
here you want to go
sort by sight rating i'm still number
one
i'm still number one even after he made
that video that 600 000 views
basically begging all of his fans to
come up he's not even on the list
bro he's not even on the list but here's
what i'm going to do
because you guys know that when it comes
to wikifeed i don't [ __ ] around
at all okay this is what
dude this is all i have okay
this is all i have left first of all i'm
gonna ask you guys i'm not gonna ask you
guys to fudge the numbers i would never
do that but i will say this
if you think i have the best feed in the
game i'm gonna invite you to come over
to my wiki feed page
and give it five stars to further
solidify my title
i wanna talk about feet and then what
i'm going to do further you guys
is i'm going to look up what's his last
name charlie what
charlie critical i i don't know let me
type charlie see what happens see he's
laying on the [ __ ]
nobody knows what his goddamn last name
is char critical
how the [ __ ] i find this guy i can't
even find his damn account so
it's so obscure
he's trolling you really think that's a
troll video i'm sorry
that's like a war video he called his
feet the helen of troy [ __ ]
i am i am helen of troy hell in a feet
his last name is white charlie white
really kind of a curveball
would never expect that his last name
was white
okay he's got a dude dude i didn't even
bro i didn't even
try i didn't even ask people but he's
below five now
and um and listen with someone and
here's what i'm going to tell you guys
again because i would never fudge the
numbers i would never ask anybody to rig
the game
but i would ask you guys to go to
charlie white's page and give an
honest review of his feet it might
happen to be a one
might happen to be a one star
i personally think he has a one star
foot and that's what i'm going to give
him
one star ugly here let's take a actually
gone honest look at his feet
who cares what is this what is this
[ __ ] uh
toontown i don't know what that means
just felt like saying it
uh f tier easy right all right
look at this tryhard wikifeed bait next
let's look at jacksepticeye actually one
star
that's it that's what he gets and you
guys know this is all i have so please
charlie's talking about you on his
stream live oh he's live
wait okay let me pull this off i'm
watching it i'm watching it right now
wait how do i okay you tell me should i
pull it up or well then it's just gonna
be comfortable
we have dueling streams
[Laughter]
he walked away from the camera oh he's
not watching
he's that he resigned
well the war is on the war was already
on this [ __ ] coward called
war oh what do i gotta watch a
butterfinger ad
[ __ ] this stop paying him butterfinger
money
[Laughter]
well he kind of needed to get his own
people some of the comments
h3 declared war on you
yeah this is not a war you want this is
dude you you're stepping to the ground
he's he's just sitting floating in space
he's coming to be foot war
he's moved on he's he's like already 20
videos past the subject
i'm not moved on it's war [ __ ]
that's right
all right i'm just i honestly i didn't
have to do anything because
he's already sub five and i'm like what
in the [ __ ] was that
what i saw a weird ass picture oh [ __ ]
the h3 fans are there now
this is they're spamming you they're
spamming they brought on this video
yes not fans soldiers soldiers
you know and i gotta i kind of have to
further call charlie out
because when he posted that video people
pointed it out they came out and said yo
charlie just gotta point it out ethan
has number one feet not only number one
youtuber
he's literally number one on the site if
you sort by rating
i'm number one i've got the merch what
the [ __ ] dude
i mean we've got the merch what the [ __ ]
who are you
you know what i mean who are you dude i
think i have to make an h3 video i think
i really have to make an h3 video
about this to clap back on oh my god
his stream is all now saying hi aby hi
hey but i think i really think i have to
clap back because it's like you remember
when
some ordinary gamer made that video
about me
donation shaming jeff bezos yeah i have
to protect my reputation this is way
worse
it's way worse than that that's what i'm
saying right
i have to protect my reputation i would
be like this
chris the youtuber known as critical
recently put out a video stating that he
has the best feet on youtube
i think i i think this war i think i
have to make that video
well anyway i tweeted adam and this
[ __ ] coward
peace and love but i said yo i accept
your apology
i says if you sort by
sight writing i'm number one you can
clearly see it says 6.57
6.57 right
i accept your apology he never
acknowledged it
he wouldn't even acknowledge it dude
coward h3 out of context we love him
fake news he said so this had five
thousand upvotes i mean people were out
here it's an outrage
six point five seven five minutes the
war on truth
this is fake news how can we live in a
society where truth doesn't matter
right some comments in support of me
so he clearly knew about this right
someone make sure charlie doesn't check
ethan klein's wiki feed she'd be
distraught
so he didn't acknowledge how was he
gonna go on and not acknowledge that
he's that i'm number one
all right it's so
i think i'm gonna have to i feel bad he
doesn't know about ethan who has like a
seven out of five
[ __ ] yeah that's right so you know
let's check the ratings now ethan klein
wiki feet
oh god yeah we're looking pretty oh i
didn't rape myself ever
beautiful feet if i don't say so myself
charlie white
surprising last name can we check
jacksepticeye
4.9 dropped a little bit shame
what's your let's just sean [ __ ] i
want to smell feet
really i never said that i do have
beautiful feet you said that that's a
sound bite
zach i don't believe you you said i want
to smell feed it was there
you said it impossible play it again
zach
i want to smell feet that's not me
that's you
sorry what's his last name mick [ __ ]
it's mick laughlin
mclaughlin m-c-l-o-u
ian thank you ian actually did something
like all you guys just watching me
flounder ian was in
i was done suffering from covet swoops
in
gives me the link mclaughlin
oh it shouldn't be looking hey dan i'm
immune and i can't give it to you so
that's good
okay thank you don i mean he's got a
good rating but you know what i mean
can i see a close one wait what i got
i'm sorry it's just not me he didn't do
anything he's just okay you know what
i'll give him i'll give him a four there
you go there you go well let me
let me look at his feet yeah let's be
honest
these picks are not good enough what is
this like a foot blob i can't there's no
detail hey dan that's not bad
huh dan what do you think is that not
bad or what
i don't think his feet are five star
worthy
not five five no no i agree not five
mm-hmm
really they're not terrible they're not
one not terrible but not five yeah
i'm trying to look for a good clean shot
of his feet would you fart on those feet
i don't know what flip fetishes are and
i'd farted who exactly are you asking
i'd fart on his feet so apparently what
the foot fetish is he's got that stinky
worn soul which they like
look that's gross so i think the four
stands the fourth stance
has charlie responded to the gauntlet or
is he ignoring it once again
he's not in this he's still not in the
stream yet yeah of course by the way is
it
a coincidence that he disappeared the
moment i call him out on this
um someone said you should paint your
toenails for the video
put some nail polish i'll go get like a
whole petty well they just you think i
should go get a whole pet i can't they
closed them all yeah i wish i
could you can bring someone here just
drinks
that's so bougie bring someone to my
house i mean
are you the king of wikifeed or not oh
but i can't
i can't tell if they should look pretty
or girls because people like
like like a girl like they want to fart
on your feet
i don't like that he's back
back he doesn't have the courage to
respond so i wouldn't be surprised
charlie is back you know what uh we
gotta do our uh ad reads
we do we're yeah hey we haven't actually
run a little late but uh
what about so good i didn't want to
interrupt i have an update oh go ahead
we got
he just said i admit i was wrong i
didn't do my
thank you buddy well we love you he just
avoided a full out [ __ ] war bro he
didn't want that smoke
yeah he didn't he really hold it quick i
thought he'd but i'm happy
that's very mature of him that being
said my rating still stands
one star one star
[ __ ] i'm laughing cause you big mad
we should send him a signed week if it
had
i'm sending him one of these smells like
my ass candles so we should include a
sign
here we could include one of the signed
wiki here let's sign it on stream right
now
yeah here we go give me a give me a
sharp here you know what charlie
to commemorate our piece we have an
extra wiggy feet hat
it's authentic snap back you can see you
know we got stock
of those yeah we just give these out to
all of our podcast guests
we have uh the authentic snapback
sticker still on it
mint condition this is for you charlie
i probably have sharpies upstairs from
me number one on wikifeet.com ethan
klein five
seven stars out of five with peace and
love
i think i'll just give you a big fat
kiss
you might find it in the first drawer
dan's looking for a sharpie he's running
like a maniac
his chat is telling him ethan's going to
send you an ass candle
yeah he knew he knows all right i had to
get his address
but i'm sending him an ass candle
because he did the goop review
um so i thought he might enjoy the
really the yin to the yang on the on the
candle front
dan is running at full speed
well done dan thank you dan thank you
thank you dan
so here we have the commemorative
wikifeed hat this commemorates
this is the olive branch the deck the
the
peace treaty that was signed on this day
from us the victor to you the uh
i think this was the biggest and
shortest war
in history i'm a little disappointed
because i kind of wanted to make that
youtube video
so here let me write basically we got
peace i'm gonna write well
sometimes it cares about peace
uh two to
charlie to charlie
always always
[ __ ] come right like always number two
from ethan
number one in parentheses
yeah he's going to look at this and make
fun of me
you can't even read that here you go
this is it you want to add anything
i just want to say peace and love peace
and love
i feel like this is a momentous occasion
yeah
i'm glad he finally acknowledged that he
was wrong because yeah he's [ __ ] up
peace and love peace and love okay
charlie we're sitting did you send the
candle already or no
no okay so great so we'll include this
with the candle so
wicky wikifeet thank you very much that
was great
peace ap said he's being spammed with
gerd gang
i think we need to be wikifeed gang like
gerd gang isn't doing it i think we need
to
wikipedia gang look feet get or wiki
feet you're good
pretty good yeah you're not gonna
continue okay gang is good
we're the gerd gang i feel like um
okay i'll think about it guard gang is
good let's not let's not try to
you know force something i was going to
say it was something like we could fit
in malaysia
would you be militia we're armed and
ready
and we're armed and ready for combat
gonna smell our [ __ ] feet
already
okay that was fun
[ __ ] god damn all right you guys want
some ads let's go
roman who wants a boner
it's boner time boys
look we know it can be awkward or
embarrassing to talk about erectile
dysfunction usually we brush it off or
blame ourselves
but roman is here to get you the advice
that you want the help you need with
no shame how often do you use excuses
like i had a long day at work or i'm
just not feeling it
it isn't easy to talk about erectile
dysfunction but roman makes it easy
to discuss and treat your e talk to me
baby a healthy life includes a healthy
sex life
but if you struggle with erectile
dysfunction you may not feel like your
best self
if you want help with ed roman connects
you with a real
us licensed health care professional who
can prescribe the medicine you need boom
roman you can get a free online
evaluation ongoing care for ed all from
the comfort and privacy of your home
a healthcare professional will work with
you to find the best treatment plan
if medicine is appropriate roman will
ship real medicine with free
two-day shipping the whole process is
straightforward simple and discreet
getting started simply just go to roman
get roman.com h3 and complete an online
visit
erectile dysfunction used to be tough to
talk about now there's roman
complete an online visit today to
connect with a doctor and take care of
it just go to getroman.com
h3 to get 15 off your first order of ed
treatment
a free online visit and free two-day
shipping that's getroman.com
h3 for 15 off your first order of ed
treatment getroman.com
have any of you guys ever had trouble
getting it up
unfortunately yeah i mean outside of uh
maybe a night with way too much drinking
you know
there was a point in college where i
when i was suffering from extreme
anxiety that i
i almost i couldn't get it up like for
the whole year and it was
horrible that's gotta be super stressful
it's so [ __ ] up because like
if you're with somebody you like and you
actually like them and you are attracted
to them but you're just so anxious you
can't get it up it's like
it's hard to you know women look at you
and they judge you like but well they
they think it's a
reflection on themselves that's the
problem they don't necessarily judge you
they think like oh what's wrong with me
which is so [ __ ] up because you're
like i do
you know trust me i'm right i would
[ __ ] i would basically give a nut to
get hard right now
now i'm sorry to like go back off topic
but there are two great titles
food soldiers oh the foot soldiers and
wiki fleet
the wiki fleet well the problem with
wiki fleet is that you don't
but you don't know which wiki there's
too many wikis right foot soldiers is
hilarious though
baby you've had uh problems getting it
up you were quick to respond tell me
about that
yeah i had a rough summer i don't know
really oh with your wife
no it was actually it was the summer
before i met her oh
yeah and you're right it's just awkward
because then you feel bad because the
girl thinks it's her and
right was it just like an anxiety thing
you think
uh i think that was part of it yeah
were you drinking or was just like a bad
it was a bad thing
it just got bad yeah it's a bad
moment it was it was an exciting summer
i think i was just off
a little bit there's a bad penis moment
yeah okay so much going on yeah we all
been through that even ian is nodding
it's like man we've all been through a
bad penis moment
it's a horrible feeling too then you
know it's actually interesting because
you never hear anyone talk about it so
yeah it is embarrassing you don't want
to talk about it what ian
yeah i was saying but then you take this
product you look down at your pants
and uh is it the is it the utah desert
because there's this freaking obelisk
down there
dude ian's front on another he's on
covet
planet right now
that's true though i'd like to have an
obelisk in my pants
you know what i mean extraterrestrial
boner over here
i i got a scenario though like you ever
like you go out on a date and like you
don't eat anything all day and you got
like the empty stomach dump
so that prevents you from like getting
hard has that ever happened to
anyone empty stem stomach dump so you
poop
it's like pushing on your prostate so it
kind of you know takes away from the
fact that over your life you know oh
that's enough for me i did
yeah sorry i feel like two things
we shouldn't be ashamed of talking about
is this for guys and period for girls
that's true it's like it's just like
embarrassing to talk about your period i
don't know why
yeah like why because it grows yeah i
guess
i guess guys are gross it's gross yeah
and it's by the way i think that i think
that feminine products should be free
i think it's absolutely [ __ ] that
women have to be strapped with the cost
of this really expensive hygiene product
i just read some place just uh past a
thing that it's
yeah they made it free oh really yeah it
was scotland i think in scotland they
passed a thing that all
but think about it women have it's
really expensive
products remember when we were broke
every time we'd have to buy all this
stuff it's like geez
yeah yeah i try to buy something else
right now
yeah so i am pro free feminine hygiene
products
that's my platform anyway go to
getromand.com for boner
i stuff me undies too political too
political
how is this politics too political
you know what should be free also
condoms how is this politics
condoms we're talking about blood and
penises planned parenthood
yeah and uh well i guess this is just an
l.a thing wait
there's some places there's lots of
places where i'm waiting are people
joking are they serious about that
they're not joking i think they're just
joking
yeah they are i can't imagine me okay
let's talk about me
undies the holidays could be a stressful
time of the year
if only there were some bearded men with
a bottomless bag of everything that need
to cross off the list thankfully our
friends at meundies have the next
best thing i wanna i a santa
and just underwear to come down my
chimney true
all like bared out like yeah baby
thick ass santa claus hmm
the undies curates a list of stuff your
friends really want this year so you can
soften the holiday stress
i gotta say usually i would not like
underwear as a christmas present
or a present but me undies is definitely
a great gift because
right it's soft and it's amazing and
it's made of
micro modal which is not it's got like
cool fine prints it's not like um
hanes oh plaid
plaid plaid paint sucks bro i hate that
underwear i wear it
and it gets like starts to disintegrate
after a year i'm wearing it right now
actually for some reason
but it sucks it's like oh well the
underwear literally dissolves off your
body
not me undies it's made of micro modal
which is not only super soft but
breathable light and impossibly cozy
it's everything you need to have a
stress-free comfortable holiday
gift some me undies with me on these
sustainably soft underwear pj sets
slippers and more
god damn it here's the offer mendes has
a great offer for our listeners for any
first time purchase you get 15 off and
free shipping
me undies also has a problem free
philosophy if you're not satisfied with
any product for any reason
you refund it you get a full refund or
exchange
no questions asked no they guarantee no
sniffing
at the factory when you return them
they say we promise we will not sniff
your used underwear
which i appreciate so to get 50
off your first order and free shipping
go to meundies.com
h3 that's meundies.com h3
there you have it folks so somebody
you're saying somebody's desperate to
make me laugh
let's do some do we have some lined up
you guys want to read some of the chats
too yeah of course let's read some chats
yeah so uh we have reagan uh for 14.99
so today is my 22nd birthday i'm so glad
i get to watch your stream because i
can't do anything because of covid
and watch every week before i go into
work love you guys
thank you happy birthday thank you thank
you
thank you with peace and love thank you
thank you
uh from mega awesome nerd for fifty
dollars dipping in my post birthday
funds to give ian some cash for a pizza
pie or whatever he's feeling
oh no wait i gotta give that mine to ian
and ethan gets a five percent tip toll
free i hope you get better from the
cover
oh wow so ian did you hear that that's
very nice i appreciate it so wait he
donated 50 but i get five percent so
that's 250 right
[ __ ] all right i gotta go send you by
the way in case you guys wonder
somebody donated 100 for zach because he
was getting memed on and i said did i
send you 100 zack
you did something 100 so there you go
nice
yeah he's a stand-up stand-up man well
it'd be kind of douchey to keep
it to be honest but now i owe you 50
bucks thanks dude
i have one general answer to a lot of
people that i see ask
kind of similar questions if you want to
send us anything about teddy fresh like
you want to work for us or anything like
that um
just send it to support teddy fresh
because they will forward me
whatever is relevant to me
that's it thank you villa any other uh
comments donations make ethan laugh
yeah if you want to make ethan laugh
message zach on uh
discord gabe we just have uh one from
measured
i'm sorry i'm not sure the currency but
says greetings from belgium
really enjoy the podcast i would
probably guess that it's
currency from belgium don't they use
euros there
yeah five euros
you couldn't tell it was a euro sign
i've never been over i don't know
i don't know what it looks like [ __ ]
maybe
[Laughter]
bruh i've never bought anything from
overseas
i've never bought anything from overseas
i mean not that wasn't in us dollars
when i purchased it like you've never
like
anything from england like no that's a
pound but that's not they don't use
yours
well i i thought he was a friend in
general
take that [ __ ] off bro no you come at me
bro
you know i'll come at you i got a theory
as to why you're actually wearing that
suit
okay why is that oh what is that because
a comment ethan made on the last episode
what did he say he said amy's the
heartthrob of the show
oh okay you think that's it you think
that's it bro
interesting interesting exactly wait
[ __ ] nailed it wait
that's really interesting exactly did
that bother you that i said abey's the
heartthrob of the show
no i mean abe and i are supposed to
support each other and like
we have to come at me but out of a
loving place baby you know that
all right hold on because he kind of is
hitting on something true because
before a b came i feel like you were the
heartthrob of the show
drama in the chat zach is still the hard
time
i think i think oh no you don't have to
push me up here a.b
i can handle myself but i appreciate it
i mean it did take it felt a blow
looking alive
do you feel that you're do you feel that
you're more handsome like who do you in
your mind
like let's be honest are you the
heartthrob is abey's title warranted or
do you think that you should hold that
title
you know be honest it takes a true man
to realize when he's wrong and say
certain things
and i think i have to give it to abe wow
so you think abs is more handsome you're
saying it right now
i i yeah wow i think he's got a better
body
than me and he's damn sexy he's he's
just being that's nice
all right zach zack is like six four
beautiful man beautiful hair
he's tall that is completely false he's
not six four though
i'm six three six three really i
remember that's
awesome i haven't seen you in like a
year
yeah zach's really tall what does ian
think about all this
y'all know dan's the heartthrob of the
show
well a.b do you think you're more
handsome than than zach no i definitely
don't
be honest i i i'm really hard on myself
in general maybe you're kind of like a
self-hater right
yeah i'm really happy but you have to
acknowledge the amount of
attention you get right like that that
yeah no it's very sweet
um people are thinking i always
attribute it's like you don't believe it
right like
no i don't believe it for a second let's
do a poll people are saying
my siblings are the same way my i don't
know yeah
i think should we do just zach and abe
yeah let's just use zach yeah i mean
let's be honest nobody wants to [ __ ] any
of us
[Laughter]
i see people that they have a crush on
dan
yeah and there's some guys and well ian
look they're all off the market
and they're on the market though so are
they technically but right
they all love baby yeah okay we're
throwing up a poll in the chat
to find out i just gotta say abe is such
a great new addition to the team
right and um he's a great dude
so a b thanks buddy if anyone still
doesn't understand what happened
ab was a simp
no it was an h3 fan all these people
stop hold on
everybody needs to stop spamming i'm
trying to put the poll in the chat and
you're all spamming too much it's just
immediately disappearing okay everybody
slow down slow down we need you who's
the heartthrob
that's a [ __ ] simple yeah a lot of
people still don't know where i came
from somehow see i was trying to
to say something but i'm so awful at
this i don't even know what i said can
you explain
yeah a b was well okay a b made
a couple of videos about us in my
defense whichever you know when the
whole goku r thing was going down a b
made like a video
defending me which was really nice
because nobody was ever [ __ ]
it was the only one on planet earth i
was like is anybody
else gonna say anything for me in this
[ __ ]
nobody maybe was the only one so anyway
i knew of him
and we started talking on twitter and i
learned a little bit about him
and lena his wife and um
you sent me like just out of the blue
because you were you were pretty simply
pretty hard
and sending me all kinds of stuff which
was nice but i was like he's a sim
which is fine and he sent me um
what was it what was the research you
said we were talking about someone and
[ __ ] was going down with you
between you and someone and then maybe
was like hey i got you back here's a
full research on this which was really
good i was like oh this [ __ ] this is
rules what
who's it on was it mike from s-i-m-p
yeah i was i was mike from impulsive
oh during that whole thing where he
called me up for being like uh
he's like dude whenever you think
whatever whatever the [ __ ] bro you're
such a
chauvinist yeah and meanwhile meanwhile
by the way
cut to a couple months later and mike is
like wearing them
dresses for [ __ ] i was like okay i'm
like you're so [ __ ] woke
shut up you [ __ ] box me no i'm kidding
i won't box anyone i'll get my ass beat
i'll get my ass beat from anyone bro
but it sent us this document of research
and we were like
we want to hire well a b was like here's
all the reasons why mike
is [ __ ] a dumbass on this topic and i
was like
this is great and we were looking for
another cast member to handle help us
with research and stuff so i was like
me and you talked about it because they
were living in detroit at the time and
we're like
well and then we were also looking for
like an office manager for teddy fresh
and lena was like oddly perfectly
qualified for that job too
and so we were like this is weird like i
know it's kind of a weird
risky thing to hire these guys
especially to have a move out from
detroit
but ultimately we decided to do it
and lena has been amazing too on the
teddy first side everyone loves her
yeah she's great yeah we are internally
grateful and and abe has been awesome as
you guys know he's he's
you know the whole content court was his
invention which i love
and by the way people have been asking
was the next one we're working yeah we
want to make sure it's good we don't
want to uh
waste we don't want to waste the format
we want to make sure it's good
but uh ab it brings a lot to the table
and so does alina and i'm
super happy that that we that we brought
him out here i mean it's been awesome so
that's really the genesis of uh a b
and lena so the the votes are still
flowing in but it
the ratio is holding pretty steady at 65
percent a b
wow that's pretty good 64. 64 percent a
b
er can i pull up the polls i'll say you
understand this election
can you send me
[Laughter]
just to add on to that not not to plug
myself but you guys might have because
not a lot of people know you might have
heard of me previously because ethan and
ila talked about me
right under my youtube name which was
starting so like
i see it on the right a lot a lot of
people don't know that
star killer star killer
one cause you on that channel you were
always wearing a mash that was part of
your life right so right so
i was just the same person yeah right
yeah it seems like i'm in love with you
then and there you go
it seems like a b is winning i'm sorry
zach to say but you know what it's okay
you know you've got a lot of people
seeing the torch you did get i sent the
torch off to him
it's okay i just if you were to see us
in person it would be different i'll say
that
well the tr no i mean okay
um anyways thank you guys appreciate i
think i think good friends
is beautiful here on this show yeah but
amy's more beautiful that's what we're
getting huh
[Laughter]
i'm gonna go crying yeah but zach you
you pulled like a [ __ ] you pulled a
porn star bro not many people can say
that
so i mean whatever this poll says you
know
since we did bring up mike go ahead
yeah we forgot to address this how is
this not my document you guys uh
wait i don't even know what you're
talking about because zach said he would
never date a porn star when we're
talking about mike
right oh so i missed this whole song
who's got that link hold on zach let me
stop you there
we need the we need to pull up the clip
who's got that
i'll find it give me a second oh that is
funny people didn't know you were
starkiller
oh they didn't yeah nobody knows because
we call him because he shows his face on
his channel i figured people knew
usually he has the mask on i mean you
did a lot of videos without the mask
okay well whatever he's starkiller
right okay zach i also real quick i want
to
throw zach a little bale in the poll
real quick
because i think abe has some
he's got some sexy mood lighting that i
think does a huge
look like a [ __ ] tomato yeah you you
your camera honestly looks like [ __ ]
well that's well yeah and i said that
too i
you should go to zach's room oh look at
ian
like look look what happens
how the [ __ ] did you do that so fast
what are you doing what kind of magic
he just set up the lights he had those
he just hadn't flipped them on
yeah i went to a different room how does
he do that so fast he's [ __ ] just
been on one man
i love carmillion cove and ian rules
i think you should give zach um a little
home visit
and do a little magic in his room yeah a
little mood lighting over there
a little makeover well i don't know you
guys getting covered
together i think let's see the pictures
of you guys together no that's not a
good pick don't let
me see the picture it's not good i don't
care i want to see you guys together
because don't you think aby's sabotaging
then if he's like there's pictures of us
together
because he's kind of playing up that
he's the heartthrob and he's throwing
you under the bus if it's not maybe
you do not oh no i'm saying that show me
the picture a.b
who are you loyal to me or him
you got it zach you know better he's got
to show it to me
i look terrible in that picture he's
upset okay zach is upset
upset
[Laughter]
okay guys a very hard thing to do i just
want you to know that
all right here it is okay you ready so
zach
who we all forgot but apparently the
foot the uh gerd gang did not forget
the foot soldiers i love the fudge
so let's watch this um i'm cool bro
i don't i don't want to do that i don't
want to spot your girl's panties
all i said was like i wouldn't have sex
with her while he got attacked me for
that well hang on you all you said was
that you wouldn't have
you wouldn't date or [ __ ] a porn star
yeah
exactly who are you dating
[Music]
[Laughter]
so what the hell your whole thing
against mike was that you didn't you
were like
i won't [ __ ] a porn star so i changed my
mind [ __ ] it who cares
you changed your mind you evolved in
that short period of time
to to be fair to be fair
his his girlfriend is even [ __ ] guys
but yours is
right right right
you know what i will say though zach is
just owning everything
yeah yeah yeah zach i [ __ ] said it
yeah so
what yeah i'm not gonna deny it i love
it i love you
i love all you guys but to be fair i was
i was in a
very toxic relationship at the time okay
where i was being filtered oh so if you
had uh if you had said
um if you had said that you would date a
porn star that would have been
a pain in the ass in your relationship
correct
a little bit of sense then looking back
at that at that relationship zach you
were very filtered you're like i can't
say that
you couldn't say anything you couldn't
even say that you wanted to look at
bella's only fans
you were getting in trouble it was i was
it was just this impending
you know i'm not i'm not going to talk
bad about her but yeah it was just this
this
it just wasn't it wasn't good well i
feel like the porn star suits you
yeah i think so too
that's awesome so yeah it's just i look
i [ __ ] said it
i'll eat my words and i do whatever i do
what do you got for me amy send me a
picture
that is funny though regardless
okay here's the photo let's see
oh you got your what uh lena is in here
too yeah she's always trying to get in
between us
so wait lean is in the back seat you got
zach why are you sitting shotgun his
wife is in the back seat what the [ __ ]
i offered i'm like hey do you wanna i
have a two-door my car is very small
she yeah she she fits okay
i'm weird so what so what are we gauging
here
you asked for i don't know it's not a
bad picture yeah bad picture of you zach
yeah
i don't know what you're tripping about
oh yeah i gotta that night was that was
so much fun abe
rolls up and he's got like this
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
i said i said that night was a lot of
fun abu pulls up and he's like a fat
cigar in his mouth smoking in the car
what wow i have a cigar
so usually smokes i don't remember well
guys we've
we've covered a lot of ground there
let's move on to the next story
who's this girl gabby demartino i don't
know who that is let me look up photos
of her
so she had gotten to this really weird
controversy on only fans gabby
who is she she is a
dance youtuber she's like an actor dance
camp she's just a youtuber here she is
there's someone who said in a super chat
honestly i'd i'd kill to add another
woman to the h3 team
to banter with these boys i'll give them
a round for their money on
stories and research i'd love to hire a
female i don't know i think
i think if anyone thinks they can do it
just send us whatever you know
send us a resume send an email to
podcast issues you want to go ahead and
do research on something do that well
you know the last three people have
hired ian
all the guys ian zach how did we hire
you zach i forget
he uh emailed him he talked about on the
show that we wanted
we wanted a sound we wanted a sound guy
and he just emailed and said hey i live
in the area
so all three of these guys were hired
through their
outreach yeah i didn't know any of them
i had no connection to either them
except that they
they reached out i should say too i mean
we are in
currently in the works of getting our
new studio
and moving into a new building and kind
of expanding the whole operation
dude it's going to be so sick next year
wait till you guys see what we're
building
yeah and there will be some open right
exactly i mean there's
the opportunities will will likely
expand around the spring
of next year we should try to hire a
woman that'd be all right
i would love another female voice in the
midst of us
so thank you dan thank you dan you got
it don
so this is gabby d martino who has an
only fan's account
okay and the controversy is that
she is peddling a nude
video of her as a child
for three dollars okay
so weird 25 year old shared a video of
herself as a kid
with the caption won't put my panties on
d martino's only fan account has since
been taken down
what so so she's she's selling nudes of
herself as a kid on our only fans
there's a link in there of the ad yeah i
want to see that's the
i think that's the best thing to kind of
demonstrate what's going on so here this
is a video explaining it
okay thanks
[Music]
i'm chris hanson with dateline nbc can
you dateline herself
it's like have a seat over here so yada
yada yada
well that doesn't mean anything really
does it i don't know chris
you're the expert what the [ __ ] do i
know
so here unlock for three dollars won't
put my panties on
she reportedly cap that's what a sick
[ __ ] weird wait in this video
you gotta open the link because they're
not showing it
okay but i kind of want to give the
contact she said she apologized on
twitter claiming she thought the video
was nothing more than a goofy family
throwback
i mean i don't buy that you're on only
fans and you said i won't put my panties
on
like yeah what a sick thing to do
i mean what a weird weird weird i like
to make love
childhood video chris what
hey childhood video of me on the phone
saying nanny
says put your panties back on and
jumping up and down laughing
sorry i didn't think that one through
period a home video
i love to share with my friends and i
use my only fans as a
finsta page well then why are you making
people buy it for three dollars can't
you post it for free if that's the case
zach uh yeah
yeah yeah i'm just asking you because i
know you're i
i only fancy i know for sure you use it
yeah yeah yeah yeah
so weird and even just don't post that
like that's a
that's a disgusting close family you
know what i mean
oh man
i'll make it feel really good for you
hon oh
chris that's just not appropriate what
anyway she got permanently banned which
is kind of epic i don't know how big her
account was
but let me pull up this photo that let's
see so
uh image from the original post oh god
here we go
so this is her the way she advertised it
right here this is what you would see
sent a little surprise in your inbox is
for those who are curious
yeah and then you see that photo and
then you buy it and all of a sudden
you're looking at child porn
oh why oh my god what
what i would if you're why you'd buy
that and be like
what yeah that's fbi it's like the
minute you unlock it you get a knock at
the door
yeah right over there every eye's here
dude seriously that's kind of like i
think a lot of her fans must have been
like
tonight that's really wrong
oh my goodness because i thought at
least they knew what they were clicking
on
but this means it's like insane they
weren't even trying to buy it
yeah and then she's like here's the
here's what you asked for
let's see her apology is short or is
this the super cut
i'll just be your secret love judgment
and
poor decisions have led to a very very
serious issue that needs to be addressed
i owe it to you guys as i was coming up
with new ideas and new content
i was watching a home video with my
family of myself as a three-year-old
when my mom announced that she was
pregnant with my younger brother
in that home video i ruined a beautiful
moment by telling everyone that i heard
my nani tell me to put my panties on
through a stethoscope it's a video that
has brought back laughter and joy within
my family for years and i sure chris
what do you think
oh then stop caption it's not funny it
was a quote from the video
never in a million years did i think
something that i thought was so innocent
could be looked
in such an ugly way and i think that's
where the problem lies i
realized i'm so disattached with reality
that it didn't even cross my mind that
this could be viewed like this and
that's a serious issue it's not funny it
will never be funny
and it's not okay and i'm really sorry
i'm sorry two friends pretty sincere
seems like a pretty good apology yeah
i'm truly sorry
and it was definitely a huge lack of
my character and my judgment and i know
who i am
in my heart and i know that if you know
me you would know i would never condone
anything like this
so it really what was on the agenda no
the pain that i've caused for so many
people
my family my friends my fans my
supporters even people who have just
simply been triggered by my stupid
thoughtless action
to everyone i'm very very sorry it was
very insensitive and a poor
representation of who i am and what i
believe in
i would never do anything to exploit or
harm a child
i'm so sorry truly very sorry this is a
huge wake-up call
i'm gonna step back into reality now and
i'm gonna reflect
and i love you guys and i'm so sorry i'm
i'm going to grow and learn from this
and i will come out of this a better
person and i will do that that's gotta
be one of the better youtube apologies
eh yeah
that made me sad
let me just read the comments i'm
curious
it's got the likes disabled well the
comments are here
google what is i'm not looking
what the [ __ ] what are they saying to
look it up
you know exactly doing you're sick i
hope you get charged with selling cp
can you get charged with cp if it's
yourself it's kind of an interesting
thing right i think so i mean yeah you
should be able to but
hiding dislikes coward yeah youtube
comments are not kind
not kind not cut so that was a weird one
she straight up said she's detached from
real i mean she's basically
acknowledging
she's an idiot i mean what more can you
want from an apology even for that you
know i don't know anything about her so
i can't possibly say
she didn't try and justify it anyway she
said i'm an idiot like
okay which is so weird i think the if i
have there's any evidence that she
is being truthful here is that she
didn't try to sell it like cp
she was like it was weird the way she
marketed it
right anyway speaking of uh
speaking of sexual
how do you say sexual uh deviancy
deviance thank you den how you doing
how you doing
[Laughter]
so this is before you before we move on
it's okay if i read this donation
yeah um from jesse plummer uh she said
uh so thankful for the h3 crew tomorrow
i go back to work after three months off
after suffering from ptsd
i was a covet host hospice nurse during
the height of the pandemic
please use this as a psa stay home for
the holidays
also ela kleiner for life wow thank you
for your service you're a friend
you are the hero of this family
the people working on the front line are
just [ __ ] heroes man
thank you for your service gonna be so
scary you're seeing so many people
all the time and yeah thank you for for
your service really
you know sad
hope you get better hope you feel better
so let's let's talk about uh this guy
who
this girl on tick dock who apparently
[ __ ] her son-in-law now shall we
sally do we have anyone for make ethan
laugh by the way
uh everyone keeps sending poop stories
we have a we have a no poop story policy
that's been instituted we have an
embargo on poop and peace stories we're
putting our foot down finally
we are we are evolving people we're
better than that
right all right honestly i would listen
to them all day but people are getting
annoyed in the comments
we do have a call lined up though i
don't know if you want to so i actually
have to pee
desperately so either you entertain so
who's the call
set them up a little bit i'll take it
like that
oh i have to pee so bad
what is that exactly
um also let me read a couple donations
okay sure um
this person is asking when will the
black beanie
from the last episode be out um
so i was kind of testing the waters i
think
it seems like everyone liked it i did
too so it will be out around february
nice ethan wasn't a fan but i'm like
it's not for you
i think it's probably for women
um
[Music]
zac is a king
sure okay so thankful for the that's the
one we just read
okay so i guess yeah let's bring on the
call
um let's kind of disappear quick
oh i can see i can see some more in the
back end here
uh let's see
right zach it's king right uh
l said please don't hire a hyper pc
person
i enjoy the unfiltered ignorance of this
podcast
not as dangerously ignorant as trisha
though okay so somewhere
somewhere between the ignorance of
trisha and and
the current level okay we're gonna find
that sweet spot keep that in mind
although we probably will hire based on
their
qualifications their capabilities yeah
right
more so than their level of victory yeah
[Laughter]
uh somebody said their credit card
company literally just called them
because they thought it was fraud from
all the
donations they were making to us jesus
dude take it easy
take it easy you want to take this call
who
did you guys introduce them no i was
reading a donation so
so um so this is a man and his wife
the wife is the only fans creator
and they get weird custom requests for
videos so i want to learn more
i'm fascinated by the only fans
experience you know i don't know how
many guys know
jem wolfie she's number one and she
reached out to me
on instagram because she's a fan of the
show and we mentioned her
and i'm trying to set it up so i really
want to talk to her about her experience
uh on only fans but let's get let's
bring him in
let's have a chat we have anthony and
arena
on the line anthony marina
[Laughter]
so reena what is the name of your what's
your name let me let me just
let me see what's happening let me just
get out oh my only
yeah all my only fans it's lucia
underscore lu
okay and what kind of content do you
make lucia
underscore lu uh fetish content
oh oh you you do wait
lucia lu i don't see it only fans what's
your name like if i google you how do i
find your stuff
um here i'll send you the link mine is
l-u-c-i-a
underscore ciao i'm trying to find
some i'm trying to find some safe for
work photo i can show
so this is who we're talking to you
might want to go on my instagram
i can't i just keep finding a bunch of
here zach zack's going to send me
so this girl lucy she does fetish
content yolo
oh so what does that mean like a whole
broad spectrum of spanish
fetish content or like specific needs
from poop feet
i put worms on me um i've done a lot
i've done a lot
you're okay you're being pooped on this
chick's wild yeah
wait worm send me a link quick zack so
are you into that stuff or you just do
it for the only yes
very into it very very so let me ask you
what is it that you're into is it like
the degradation
that you like being degraded or like
what is it like you have this
full spectrum enjoyment of fetishism
like how do you how do you like every
fetish
what is it you like i like being
degraded i like being
hurt and i like being like pushed around
damn yeah yeah so how does poopdog fit
how did you when did you first realize
you like being pooped on
yeah also is your husband the one
pooping on you
yeah yeah and what's your name dude
my name is anthony anthony how does it
feel to take a steamy dump on your wife
oh my god dude it's it's heaven it's
awesome really it's heaven really
so okay wait so you both you both were
into this separately or did you discover
it together as a couple
yeah really so were you guys like kind
of vanilla when you started dating
no not me you know oh okay so let me
zach send me a link i gotta see these
people
oh yeah she's very pretty well why are
you only saying for yourself you put it
on the screen
no it's safe for work i just i couldn't
save for work
okay is this is this you
they're on a delay so they'll see it
zach sent me this
hopefully that's you you're kissing a
polar bear
yeah that's you okay okay because
everyone else with that name is like
asian just saying
i mean i typed it and all this stuff
okay oh you're turkish hey you are
interesting
okay so so let me so when you take a
steamy dump on your wife
what's the cleanup process like or tell
me walk me through that process
just walk me through that process do you
eat something in preparation do you put
down a tarp
like i'm really just curious about the
process i just let him
poop right on me and i prefer to see his
ass
gape while he goes oh [ __ ]
and then it just kind of drops on me and
and then i just kind of leave it there
and we really show it and everything so
where did you poop like on your chest
on your chest or like your face would
you ever take it on your face or just
your
chest um i've taken it everywhere
you wouldn't put it in your mouth would
you no
um i might but i don't think there's
always a price there's a positive
there's a price for everything
it's dangerous you mean you mean oh you
mean if someone paid enough you would
put it in your mouth
yeah yeah yeah but it seems like you
like it like i don't know if that's
something
wow dude that's
crazy what if it's like a messy poop
[Music]
[Laughter]
wow how did you get so [ __ ] up and i
mean with peace and love like
how do you how do you get to be like
mommy issues
and daddy issues really it's the super
powers combined ends up with you being
pooped on
right exactly so wow well i guess that's
an easy solution are you making a good
living on only fans doing this
oh yeah my first month i made a thousand
dollars wow
yeah and so how much would you charge
how much would someone have to pay to
get a video of you getting pooped on
um the last guy paid three hundred
dollars for it
wow it's good money especially if you
like it i mean hell you know what i mean
they pay for it and then they get their
own private video
yes wow okay let me ask you this because
if i if i'm understanding you both
correctly
i get the feeling that rena am i saying
your name right
is more freaky than anthony is that
right
i i don't know man she likes different
things yeah
because it sounds different it sounds to
me like some stuff she's up for
anthony may not be up for like the
pooping in the mouth you seem more
hesitant than reena
has there ever been a situation just
said there's a prize to her yeah but at
first he was like no
[Laughter]
well in the mouth i would feel like i
was doing a disservice to her
like i don't want to give her pink eye i
don't want to get her like any kind of
you know illnesses it seems like a
bargain to be honest for 300.
right yeah right so has there ever been
anything that either one of you wanted
to do but the other person was like
that's too much for me
no you guys are kind of are you guys in
love it kind of sounds like you guys
found your soul mate
we're married yeah you're married that's
awesome yeah
what was the sex like on your wedding
night was it weird or vanilla
did you
we did like a bunch of weird role play
like we were like
other people
you guys are [ __ ] crazy and do you
guys
all in the name of love yeah yeah yeah
no dude dude i think it's
by the way i i joke but it's great that
you guys have this open sexual
relationship with each other i think
it's fantastic
yeah it's really beautiful thanks thank
you
and so it's so good vin diesel likes it
he's placing an order right now
okay so we've religiously watched you
for like years now and we actually
connected over
you guys
oh you guys yeah wow and it's so cool to
know that our show
culminated in you getting pooped on
so what's the can i ask you what's the
weirdest thing you guys have done
because i feel like i'm
who knows where the limit is on this
stuff and i'm just fascinated
well for content the weirdest thing i've
ever done was put a hard-boiled brown
egg in my vagina and it tore my [ __ ]
and i got a yeasty from it
so how much you get wait how much you
get paid for that
three hundred dollars is that that seems
like kind of the most that you'll charge
is that like for the craziest stuff 300
yeah yeah so a hard-boiled egg will give
you
your infection yeah yeah no
don't put a hard-boiled egg in your puss
because you will get a yeasty
there you go you learn something those
are important
life lessons for y'all okay wait hold on
egg doesn't seem that big to tear your
stuff
i am so tight like clinically tight
oh really tampons oh
oh my goodness i should like lube myself
like
i i honestly watch videos of belle
ela or uh megan fox to get myself
lubricated and then you want like
one that's pretty cool
how does that make you feel i'd be
honored fine i mean
but what do you watch like just the
podcast all due respect
yes i just watched a podcast out of
respect do you ever watch like a deep
fake video
wait this is great did you ever watch a
deep fake reveal or something
yes yes that's so funny
i mean that's awesome yeah that's
[ __ ] awesome
so when you say clinically tight is that
really a thing like where your vagina is
like overly tight
really it's like a condition with a
condition
that makes your vagina super tight whoa
is that a problem with like normal
vaginal sex
yes so i have to get like very
lubricated for it but i mean it makes
for better sex and more pleasure for
anthony so anthony anthony are you like
well endowed because i feel like you you
might you might even prefer a guy with a
smaller penis am i right
he's got a big dick i saw it on her own
bigger
penises why because you like the pain
yes oh you were [ __ ] crazy
zack said zach said i don't if you guys
heard him zack said he's got a huge dick
i saw it on only pens
holy [ __ ] this is great oh my god
wow well i really don't know what else
to say to you guys i feel like you guys
are doing the only fans wrong are you
just making specialized
fetish videos because i feel like if you
made more general videos you weren't
do you sell every video or do you make
general content for people to subscribe
monthly to as well
i make general content i do masturbation
regular set
[Music]
so let's give a shout out what is the
what is the only fans
lucia underscore lu there it is guys
zach's on there right now what kind of
stuff do you see well i mean
it's pretty vanilla considering
considering that
from today like an hour ago
uh yeah um
something her laying on a towel
spread legs what go ahead
eggs coming out something something in
their vagina
i gotta tell you i think pooping is
weirder than the egg and the vag
just for i kind of feel the same way
yeah pooping the pooping is way
weirder than it is like that's height
yeah do you play with it do you smell it
like what do you do with it you could
charge more for the poop
yeah i play in it smell it touch it
like everything anything you can think
of i agree i feel like 300 you guys yeah
you're undercutting yourself way short
yeah i think you could charge me well
consider
i like it it's not too much of like a
chore to do
no but you got it
did you guys hear that i think there's
someone in africa that
would like to make a request oh
and this one is eating this place yeah
we're sending him zach go ahead what
does he say
to eat that yeah he wants you to eat the
poopoo
oh my god so one of the things they do
is called
eno leaking yeah you know what i don't
know if uh
zach soundboard goes into discord
unfortunately they might not oh you guys
can't hear it
you'll hear it on the stream is there
any other ques i mean i feel like i have
a million things to ask you guys
ask me i mean i'm so open i'll answer
anything no i see
that i just i don't want to leave any
stone unturned when did you first
realize that you were like such a
sexual uh uh deviant
i was working on a farm at my aunt's
farm when i was like 14
and i got my toe stuck in a mouse trap
and it hurt really bad
but i liked it so i kept doing it and
putting
my hands in it and i liked it and then
one day i got it and put it on my
[ __ ] and it snapped and i like
squirted like
it made you feel cool man yes holy [ __ ]
but like what so obviously this is
triggered by childhood stuff like do you
have some kind of direct line where
you're like
were you yeah yeah you have yeah maybe
maybe it's not the right time to go into
all that
yeah but that's fine yeah i understand
holy [ __ ] wow the mousetrap story is
pretty epic
that's pretty so the first time you had
sex did you freak out you're
the guy who you first slept with or like
when did you start
introducing this in the bedroom so
nothing
like he was very vanilla he had a micro
penis so like
nothing yeah nothing felt like how i
wanted it
so we broke up and then i married my
husband
because of my strict household um i
couldn't really have premarital sex
so like by the way i just have to say
it's always the girls who can't have
pre-marital sex that
end up putting mouse traps on their
vagina and squirting
really ethan why let's not make
i think that's a good generalization
based on what
i feel like that's a really good
generalization based on all based on
your research
but it's like if you prohibit people
from having sex they're gonna end up
being freaks
no i agree all right
give a shout out to the girls who didn't
end up being freaked out they all are
they they end up having like anal sex
and [ __ ] it's crazy what they do
you gotta let the bull free man oh so so
your husband is only the second man
you've been with
yes interesting
so what was it like you guys you guys
were like
like was it a setup marriage or you were
just like boyfriend girlfriend but you
have to get married
we were boyfriend and girlfriend but had
to get married so
i couldn't like hold back my sexual
intentions with him because i knew he
had such a
big wiener that like i wanted it so bad
so we got married in the first six
months we started dating
so you're like [ __ ] this i just going to
marry this guy
that's crazy that's really good luck
that you guys are both down to like do
all this stuff so
god bless well guys i bless your
marriage i papa bless your marriage and
i wish you all
a fruitful and happy career and uh thank
you for sharing your story with us
and uh god bless man yeah
thank you so much thank you guys zach
are you gonna be
i love it we love it zach are you
putting in any requests with them
zach what are you thinking about
requesting i mean the [ __ ] egg
stories are [ __ ] crazy man
i mean the pooping is way worse than
that [ __ ]
i think i just want to see that out of
curiosity
dan's breathing heavily what did you
think about that call dan
i loved it no i mean what the [ __ ]
dude but she said no she said she made a
great guy
yeah she's not getting paid enough i
agree i'm not even close
i i i've i don't know if the person that
i knew did any uh uh
fecal stuff but i was friends with a
porn star
a few years back um and she did like the
weird fetish stuff like the special
requests from people like
really bizarre remember when she told
like she's
there's a lot of people that are into
balloon popping where it's like
and she just pops balloons sweet and so
just like weird [ __ ] like that and um
and yeah i think
she made like a lot more than that but
the market's much more saturated
nowadays with only fans right there's a
lot
i don't think there's many people on
only fans willing to [ __ ] and by the way
she's really pretty too
like i would i mean yeah if i saw her i
wouldn't be gorgeous
like i get what she's saying that it's
like i like it so i don't mind
yeah but come on it's business yeah i
mean got it don't sell yourself short
right
that should jack up those prices in my
opinion i think you could be making more
damn that's great dan has been fantastic
what i mean dude true love does exist i
mean there's someone out there for
everybody and like
the fact that they like found each other
and
in this conservative family where they
get married and all this i mean damn
they're actually they're excommunicated
now for sure though
after that i bless them the pope
uh the pope uh
says ish i don't think so the pope
probably likes her
the pope
[Laughter]
so interesting
i mean the poop thing is [ __ ] crazy
so you guys damn this is like this
episode of just pure deviance
so let's talk about this [ __ ] sally
youngblood on tick tock
aka teddy bear love this is just a tick
tock account so it's really not weird
okay i mean it is but it's like out
there tick tock has deemed this [ __ ]
nest
like cool so sally lives with her
husband daughter and son-in-law
she makes content often hits at her
having a sex relationship with both her
husband
and son-in-law many of the comments tell
his videos speculate that the son-in-law
and husband are being held captive
fascinating do we have a curated are
those like serious
or like or does like when people say eli
is being held kept why don't you be the
judge
i yeah i'm fully convinced they have
someone locked in the box what's
happening there
whoa you must be a bad boy that's what
happens when you're a bad husband you
get put in the kennel
say hi hi i just keep in my basement
burrito
where and who's that that's the daughter
i believe that's there's a daughter
involved
hi nate all right no you're a bad boy
look at me what you doing you're kind of
cute go back to the kennel
you're a bad boy that's what bad
husbands do they get put in that kennel
why is the daughter
come on out now say hi guys say hi to
your sister
you know once again i gotta say this is
why tick tock is the best platform in
the game
because you just never know what you're
gonna find when you scroll
oh my god it's the best why is the
daughter involved
so here's another one called candy shop
it has copyrighted music dan beware
so here this is the couple this isn't
the son-in-law right this is the couple
yeah you know yeah everybody knows that
song
oh you're playing deliverance
the dog wants a lick bruh damn dude so
this is tick-tock bruh
copyrighted music oh lord help me jesus
jesus jesus so is this her son-in-law
what uh yes i mean what
what in the [ __ ] why does he look like
what is going on here
there's a lot going on here there's a
lot going on
what's oh my bro i got it let's get out
of here
so here's one called threesome
[Laughter]
so this is i think i i think this one
showed up on my
feed it was the or maybe some
who's who someone found this on their
feed and sent it i did
yeah this is the magic of tick tock this
shows up on your feed
i don't get the weird stuff i get all
right it's barely open
is there nothing i can do i made a new
page just for the weird stuff
my page is all weird stuff bruh so it's
a song about a threesome
i mean i have to say that he doesn't
look related
like this is his song no he's not as uh
no no no so who are these people it's
the daughter's like boyfriend
or husband or something oh
wow is this what goes on out there
this is what goes on out there outside
of the big city
[Music]
you better turn that off we're gonna
claim for that [ __ ] zach they're trying
to [ __ ] lose my pants for some damn
white trash jokes disgusting
i think this dog might be part of this
love circle too because look at the dog
oh my [ __ ] christ on a stick
guy explains to haters
jesus dude this [ __ ] is so wild it's not
all so why does it matter to you
dude this guy's literally the dude from
uh trailer park boys who's never wearing
a shirt
oh randy yeah
why does it matter if we don't have
shirts on i don't even have any shirts
at all so why does it matter to you it's
not it's really none of your people
don't own
oh what a god what what's the big deal
because we don't have our shirt on
what's in his hand don't go without your
shirt on what the [ __ ] is he eating
yeah what is this house dude i love it
bro
you gotta love it man these people are
just out there living their life
and putting it on tick tock for some
reason
technically these guys right here you're
looking at me they go around naked too
sometimes in the house
hi poochie hi poochie the [ __ ] all the
haters
i really want to know what he's eating
more than anything really
kind of fasting i'm so hungry
child protective services uh oh what do
we got
called child protective services edward
go ahead call them they're not gonna do
anything anyways
okay if you want to call child texas
service on us go right ahead
there are no kids involved and if there
is kids involved
that's really none of your business
because there's nothing going on legal
in this house
for a child texas service to do anything
to you
so legally yes we do have kids in this
house but
it get hot i got a lot of i got
it's a tactical team what i love is that
sally's feeding them the lines and
they're trying to remember what their
lines are
yeah some shakespeare i think these guys
might be like
low iq not like i mean i mean that with
peace and love but like
clinically low iq you know what i mean
yeah
cause like go ahead call them they're
not gonna do anything anyways like high
pitch
he's like your turn okay if you want to
call child text or service on
i mean i mean i mean she's saying child
tective service
[Laughter]
continually that that that that
i mean it's even like in the text oh
yeah the spelling there but if something
threw me off she says
there's no kids involved as even if
there were it's none of your business
i didn't catch that yeah watch this
there are no kids involved and if there
is kids involved
that's really none of your business
because there's nothing i don't have
your business illegal in this house she
says there's nothing going on on the
eagles
oh man [ __ ] these people are well
ticked only on tick tock folks yeah man
that's a whole wide crazy world out
there bro you know those people voted
trump i'm just saying sorry i'm just
saying you know they also had no
politics
i voted trump okay
you know they have a magazine that's all
i'm saying stop
i'm the president of the united states
don't ever talk to the president
okay sorry donald sorry i know i said i
wouldn't talk about it i'm sorry donald
trump all right you are holding me you
are 100 holding the poor poor man
hostage
oh yes i am holding in the cabbage see
this [ __ ]
cabbage wait wait wait stop these people
[ __ ] serious this is literally like
trailer park boys where they
mispronounce everything
everyone all the haters out there look
at this
and look how smiley he can smile too
he's my son-in-law [ __ ]
all the haters no she's not holding me
as captage
oh yes i am holding him a cat this [ __ ]
is a lie
and then oh that's not bad huh trump
likes the family dynamic
oh my god
oh my oh my god why do you want to know
so much about my life
who the hell he is who the hell he is if
you really want to know
oh my god this is my son-in-law who is
married to my daughter
if you really want to know oh my god i
touched his chest
this one is my husband so you know i
[ __ ] him if you really want to know i
don't [ __ ] this one
so get a like [ __ ] okay i'm actually
glad that she cleared that up yeah i
believe her yeah
there's no reason to lie you wouldn't
tell the truth i feel oh you didn't
maybe disagree you don't buy it
wait till you get to the last three
videos all right more evidence coming
so here's this one has music but let's
see
cabbage
um she's right i see their only family
oh man i don't think you can even handle
that zach
i love how the dogs are always involved
i love the i love dogs
why is she doing this what do we make of
this hmm
not a lot it had like a few hundred
likes
sally hates her daughter-in-law wait
really
wait isn't her daughter-in-law her
daughter no no
her daughter-in-law is with her son and
she keeps saying stuff like i can't wait
for this [ __ ] to die
i can't wait for my my son to break up
with her notes [ __ ]
wait i thought she has a daughter she i
guess also has a son
so this has 300 likes so i mean it has
very little views this is definitely 300
something
a lot deep uh i mean it's got like a
thousand views probably you know what i
mean i have a lot for them
to take from me that's notes [ __ ]
there's only one thing a [ __ ] can take
from i don't get it
she hates her sally records her daughter
giving her son-in-law hickeys gross
oh that's disgusting buckle up yeah
it's very disgusting though
[Music]
i thought he had
who is giving him that i can't that's
the daughter i can't that's sally's
daughter giving her husband
no her son giving sally's husband i mean
sally's daughter i'm
come on
yes exactly that was disgusting
there's a lot of these now a lot of
these were too graphic to show is that
right
yeah there were some very disturbing
things that yeah don't go to the channel
like the thumbnail wow yeah
so i had to mute because there's music
but this guy looks different than the
guy was in the other videos
i think that's why there was that video
of her clarifying
it's like why is he thumbing up like
watching this
so weird yeah yeah someone's locked in
the basement 100
i want to go there for thanksgiving next
year go ahead you'll never come back
yeah they take may make quick work at
your ass we see your ass in their tick
tocks
all like zombied out yes
ain't nowhere wrong ain't nothing wrong
with me
being in my video i don't own any shirts
you'd be like i don't own any shirts
walking around topless you'll have an
excuse zach to not wear a shirt
nipple clamps nothing wrong with this oh
she posted a
bro i can't i just can't
what's with all this they're like in the
hickeys they're all covered in hickeys
this is but i want to read that message
that they wrote
i'm done oh i almost got it hang on
don't you want to know what's on the
message
i do oh it's slower now how odd
yeah that was weird we're waiting for
the uh
the here we go here we go someone thinks
it's kind of funny to report my videos
and my pictures
let me tell you something i know who's
doing it
if it keeps on going i'm going to whip
someone's ass and i'll do a damn good
job of it
you think jill scares me jail if you
think jail scares me jail don't [ __ ]
scare me at all
i want to go be in jail for a day maybe
three days till i get bailed out
i guarantee you i'll make sure you throw
the first punch
so you'll go to jail too and i'll just
use self-defense so i won't go to jail
so quit reporting my [ __ ] pictures
you stupid c word
might be talking to you either
how long we've been going i feel like we
peaked
uh almost two hours right now all right
we gotta call it off
damn we had so much going to stop on
this
shitty note what else you want i mean i
got i have a ton of stuff
i'm getting stuff on the legendary no
what's up oh
the the uh the little copeland thing
that we found yes you guys should
definitely okay where's that one
uh here i'll highlight it it's um how
are you gonna bury it and
it's right here what are we gonna do
what are we gonna do
right so you guys know the top one or
the bottom one
the top one so you guys know copeland we
talked about him he's the guy who
says you know oh my god well you
recognize him
so the story is i guess he used to make
christian movies yeah he's an actor in
certain ways and this is part of
a series of films
uh that he plays a character named uh
i think it was uh daniel lyon is the
name of his character
yeah pastor daniel lyon and it's uh part
of the um
uh these movies are called commander
kelly and the super kids
armor of light it's part of the super
kisses
jesus christ jesus so with that little
bit of all things
are possible with god
[Music]
i'll bind you sing that in the
name of jesus oh
now get out of my way
so there's some dude with a gun pointing
at him now he's on a motorcycle
speeding towards the guy with the gun
quite a show off here oh shot a bolt of
lightning
it was absorbed by the motorcycle by the
power of jesus
christ is compelling him there's like a
hologram of
uh angel with two blades
oh yeah what happened did he get him
oh he pulled right up to him he's scared
it's on the ground
are you through are you thrown get on
your knees in the presence of the
prophet
god oh he forgives him
he's telling him to pray i receive you
lord jesus
there's forehead they're forehead to
forehead
he's like i forgive you jesus and right
now
and right now if you go to copeland.com
you can get thirty percent
off silver solution which here's govid i
believe you lord jesus will you accept
the
silver solution that cures all viruses
i receive you lord jesus come into my
heart
come in that's pretty epic
that was a very peaceful uh conclusion
resolution to that conflict yeah
yeah he seems to be some sort of um
terminator like character
but he's like a god why do you have to
pepe you lost a pepe
i have no idea i was like who the [ __ ]
is i thought some random weirdo was
messaging
dan sets this up why is it called k why
is it called
dan puff it's
it says kh puff that [ __ ] it's a picture
of pepe the frog with money
what is this i don't know the background
to that
dan is goofing on me no i'm not good
what is that sure there was a few months
ago
uh there was a a a group of people that
were brigading the subreddit with a
bunch of uh hate speech and gore
pictures
and we found out that they um we found
out that they were coordinating it all
from a discord channel so i i
infiltrated their discord training from
ela
well i think i was just using that
computer so what is negaila
it's like evohila so you're trying
so you're trying to go in as nega ila to
infiltrate well that
that wasn't the name that i used was
whatever the [ __ ] i don't know did you
get any intel that's pretty funny
yeah actually thank you dan thank you
dan thank you
who knew you were undercover dude i'm
fighting i'm fighting
i'm fighting behind the scenes all right
cameron
there's no um everyone's typing
everyone's on camera make ethan laugh
yeah that's what i was trying to get at
i i you guys said this guy cameron
trying to get on is this cam like cam
grants
no it's not kim grant's you've got him
it's gonna be [ __ ] drinking
god damn it bring him on
thank you to all of our members by the
way i didn't get a chance to thank all
of you
thank you to the members who make this
show possible you help and support us so
much
you give thank you thank you thank you
thank you
is that cameron this is guys oh hey
sorry does this guy donate no i'm sorry
do your thing
you say i'm broke now please play fire
safety
oh that poor guy you know what cameron
before i forget you just stand by
i gotta play the fire safety video for
this poor guy no worries can you turn
him down a little bit dan he's like
[ __ ]
crazy turkish fire
safety vehicle just shut up yeah thank
you cameron we'll get to you in a moment
i appreciate you
peace and love i love you yeah i love
you too buddy
okay so turkish fire safety
video gone wrong i mean i don't know how
to type it yep number one
inappropriate for some users come on
this is for you dude i'm sorry i missed
it i owe you this
i owe you this so much so exhibition
the first demonstration doesn't go so
well
who do you think's in that suit like if
there was someone from the h3 universe
who would it be in that suit
joey solids you think joey you think
joey's that
luckily nobody gets hurt
that's my man
[ __ ] yeah you gotta turn off the sound
cause it gets too serious you know what
i mean
dude this guy this was a political
assassination
like [ __ ] you i love it
man this is the worst fire fighter ever
like who bro you are the worst person in
the
at that job of all time
[Laughter]
god such an animal moment like
it is so awesome i mean
it's so awesome so there you have it
is this the same guy putting it out i'd
be like dude just get
out of here bro you're done
we love it i like it buddy
so back to cameron let me uh turn it
back up one second
all right how you all doing okay cameron
you've been donating all day to try to
do it how much have you done
yeah man i'm i think i donated like 250
but
canadian yeah but it's 250 canadian
dollars so it's more like i don't know
ten dollars america no okay hold on let
me do this
250 canadian to usa here's what's on the
stake 400 that's 200 bucks
yeah yeah we're playing today for 200
bucks okay so you can go
you can break even if you make me laugh
bro i don't even want the money but i
just want to make you laugh
no i mean listen we've got to put it on
stick are you rich or something how you
got 250 bucks to throw at me
uh i'm not i mean i do okay for myself
good for you that's great thank you but
i want to i want to make you
want to pump your tires real quick um
you are my generation's howard stern
in my opinion oh is that poking what is
poking the tires maybe that sounds like
the battery
is popping out pop your tires
just want to give you a flat tire real
quick
thank you for saying that dude no you
really think that you also like drive
uh with my dad my dad was a traveling
salesman we used to always listen to
howard stern
when i was younger and then now i'm a
drive well i was a traveling salesman
until
covid um but yeah i always listen to
your podcast so i have like 10 hour
drive sometimes just throw them on and
yeah you guys all remind me of like the
howard stern crew so
just thought i'd pump you guys up a
little bit thank you thank you so much
for saying that man i appreciate that a
lot thank you
love you a lot what what are you selling
yeah what do you sell
i sell meat meat oh that's cool i sell
meat i sell you yeah it's yearly food
orders so it's like uh
that's good business people want to go
to the grocery store so i mean my job's
been pretty awesome since covid because
now i don't have to drive and i can do
it all over zoom or the phone and
you know if no sometimes i would drive
two hours and no one would be home for
my call
so now it's just people don't pick up it
is what it is so when you're not you're
selling food to like restaurants or
individuals
no homes yeah just people just uh that's
good money yeah
let's go to the grocery store yeah it's
not bad it's uh
i mean i work for my dad so he
he pays me i fairly enough but he uh
shout out barry but yeah wow that's so
interesting
yeah it's it's triple a all your way
around baby
how can i buy some can i buy some meat
from you or is it
did you deliver to the united states
i'll send it to you for free no
no no no no no no no no no no we ride
for the nation
but can i buy meat from you from usa
i i think yeah we can send it down let's
get some meat we'll do
we'll do a meat review dan get his
details let's buy some [ __ ]
stuff from this good stuff what's your
commission
uh my commission i it's
it's around like 10 15 percent just
depending on
the commission depending on what like i
said what my dad wants to do my dad's a
very
funny guy i have another funny story
about like how i became a salesman and
like my dad jipped me on my commission
and it's a funny story
we don't use gym remember that
the commission like i sold my first food
order and i didn't know what i was doing
and the commission was like 400 bucks
and
like my dad's like oh yeah i'll even
give you the commission and i didn't
know what it was at the time i was like
oh my god
and then one day we were at walmart and
i was like oh i need a new xbox
controller he's like you know what i'll
give you that instead of the commission
oh dad that's something that my dad
would do
a whole xbox controller for an hour's
worth of work oh my god
and then later on i found out that you
know he made like 360 bucks off
yeah my dad my dad would do that
business man
he did the sales process
so here's the deal we're gonna play make
ethan laugh you're very confident
obviously you've been donating a lot of
money
if you make me laugh you get all the
money back this is a big gamble two
hundred dollars u.s coming to you and a
big ass
and a meat order to boot in
the let's go okay cameron right now the
rules for 60 seconds
let's make ethan laugh when you hear the
bell
when you make when you hear the bell
ring you have 60 seconds to make me
laugh are you ready and understand the
rules
i'm i'm ready okay cameron all right
i'll count you i'll be ready go ahead
dan here we go in
three two one go
okay so it's my fiance's and i first
date we met on tinder
uh we went on our date we went back to
my place and we were in bed things were
getting a little bit frisky and she says
to me
you know i want to go further with you
but i don't [ __ ] guys unless
i'm dating them so she's like i'll blow
you i'm like okay i'm
down so she does that gets a little bit
frisky again
she it's like i same thing i'll but i'll
blow you somewhere okay so she blows me
again
and then she's like okay this third
time's happening
she says okay i want like you know what
i'm like i want to [ __ ] you i'm like
okay well like you know what why don't
we date
we're boyfriend or girlfriend now so we
have sex about a year later
we're just casually talking about people
that we've had sex with before
and i go yeah this one time i i like met
up with this girl on tinder she blew me
twice and [ __ ] me
she my fiance looked at me with the most
disgusted face and was like
wow cameron what a [ __ ] and i just
looked back at her and said abby
that was you
he got you yeah yeah and that was a
minute but so you
you managed to do it in time so how did
she react when she realized that it was
her
it's she had a great she responded great
to it she couldn't believe it she's like
oh my [ __ ] god that was me
that's funny well you know what yeah
she's gonna she's my cinderella
[Laughter]
you know what dude you formatted that
great yeah that's
great that was a great delivery it's my
salesmanship you know i can pitch
there you go yeah that was a good one
man and i'll tell you what you did
so you know i'm wearing my uh teddy
fresh rip and dip hoodie the first one
i'll tell ya
hey thank you appreciate the support
well
tell you what that 250 you donated it's
coming right back to you
as well as someone thank you some
appreciation for some meat though i'm
gonna [ __ ] order from your house
you tell dan how to order and we'll
we'll buy some meat from you or
one of these guys is already talking to
him get out get it yeah everybody get
your meat orders in
get your meat order all right cameron uh
damn we'll damn we'll get your paypal
details yeah we'll get you hooked up
thanks buddy thanks and thanks for the
launch love you guys thanks for the
launch wish you appreciate it
yeah hopefully yeah our best to
cinderella say hi to theodore
yeah thank you everybody appreciate you
take care
cameron cameron's a great one yep he
came in he pumped my tires
he made me laugh he knew how to work the
crowd he knows how to tell a story
he's got the salesman pitch for sure we
like cameron
[Laughter]
cameron's a good one all right guys
that's the show hey yeah
i'm starving hi joe that was fun eh come
on i mean we put on a pretty good show
we did all right today we did all right
we put on a good show
you know um
i'm broke and i really want to see you
look at sean valentino the womanizer
i think he's good material who's sean
valentino
never heard it we'll look into that for
next week maybe look into it john
valentino will put it on the womanizer
got it we got it zach
should we request a video from that only
fans girl where it's like something we
could show on the show
but like it's not super sexual but it's
weird enough that we you know what i
mean yeah i mean
that that could be cool i'll reach out
to her what anything in particular
i'm not sure it'd be hard to think of
something we could show on the show
that's like
weird and wild but not super sexual yeah
yeah so no poop well
i don't think we could show poops out
yeah
i'm thinking well we can think about it
wow it's been a quite a show i've
thought it was i had a lot of fun thank
you guys all for joining thank you to
all of our
members who join and support the nation
but really
everybody that watches everybody
supports us the foot soldiers are out
there
the foot militia thank you thank you
we're on
boy gotta take our guns
i do like wiki fleets yeah i'm meeting
outside wikifeed headquarters
the voice the vote was rigged boys
let me check as we wrap it up let me
check charlie's rating
mickey feet
nation we forgive but we most certainly
don't forget
i mean war is not pretty boring pretty
man and sometimes you got to do
everything you can to win
6.5 oh yeah we want to give a shout out
to our facebook page
our h3 podcast facebook page we're
trying to grow the show over there
because you know these boomer ass
[ __ ] morons use facebook and
trying to compete with all that dumb
[ __ ] like so flow so you don't have to
just like just go like the page and like
like and share our videos so that i
won't
think about this as a sales [ __ ] you
know
who cameron that we just had on the call
oh it's probably good sales which i feel
like i mean let's be honest i hate
facebook but
it's good people you know it works for
reaching people so
just go like follow it and like and
share the videos we're trying to grow it
and i mean yeah it's
you guys rule and i'm just trying to
trying to hack the system so we can get
these boomer [ __ ] morons to watch our
dumb podcast
you know what i mean stupid-ass dumb
facebook but yeah okay
we only have eight thousand followers so
we have poor um
love 20 000 people watching right now so
yeah we can double that right now
but yeah that's our that's our strategy
you know love uh out
hd out of context another fan of the
show great guy such a great guy
he lives in sweden but we hired him full
time to do our social media
and he's so good he's he's such a great
guy he's spamming the chat right now
with that link he's making it so easy
for you just click that link yeah he's
managing
our facebook page on our instagram he's
been doing a really good job so i'm
trying to recognize his
his hard work yes love is the most
silent partner in this uh
endeavor he's the silent beetle i
believe they they were right
he's he's epstein he's the he's the best
perhaps he's the what people got kicked
out um
nicole asked would you guys ever do a
your mom house lifestyle
podcast where we can pay to watch it and
you review less youtube friendly clips
i mean i don't think that i could
deliver a good enough show where i would
feel justified
charging people money
yeah i don't know it's a i think it was
works great for christina and tom
because it's so
like they go all the way they do a
really good job in planning and getting
all this stuff but
i i don't know i've got maybe when we
feel
when it feels right i don't know yeah
probably it's an interesting idea
i don't want to charge you guys you know
what i mean and again once we're out of
the
covid era and we're in a new studio
we're gonna have a lot of
more opportunities we're gonna have like
a big stage we could potentially have
musical guests we could like put on
something that maybe would be worthy of
that
maybe well guys that about wraps it up
have a great weekend have a great great
weekend please stay safe
stay god
dude charlie's going to freak when he
sees that wookie hat
signed by us so much cheaper i want to
smell
feet all right guys we love you all
right take care we'll see you on
monday we're coming hard next week i
think we're gonna have four four
episodes next week
uh oh yeah monday
yeah right all right it's tuesday yes do
we have a content court next week maybe
we should right
yes we do look at you sir four episodes
we're back baby come on h3 podcast
forever
swipe whistle agrees all right guys see
ya
love you take care
you're listening to the hd podcast what
we got on the scene
could it be papa's united bill delfin
we're talking front wiper back wife
what you gonna do with me then you know
and the whole damn crew
goose and gaps with all the guests
you'll see the best podcasts in the
world take it from me jc
over cherry hp baby we podcast
now